>> Juan: FACEBOOK BANNING SOME
FIGURES AND SOME THEY CONSIDER
DANGEROUS, NATION OF ISLAM
LEADER AND IT EXTENDS TO OTHER
PLATFORMS INCLUDING INSTAGRAM.
EMILY, WHAT STRIKES HE IS PEOPLE
WONDER IS THIS IN DEFIANCE OF
YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT OR IS
IT THE CASE THAT SINCE
FACEBOOK'S NOT THE GOVERNMENT, A
PRIVATE BUSINESS THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO STAND UP AND SAY YOU'VE
INCITED VIOLENCE AND WHATEVER
OUR STANDARDS ARE YOU VIOLATED
THEM AND YOU'RE GONE.
>> Emily: THEY ARE A GOVERNMENT
NOT A PUBLIC ENTITY AND CAN SET
THEIR OWN RULES WHICH THEY CAN
ABIDE.
I THINK THIS SAY FIRST AND AN
EXERCISE BY FACEBOOK AND
ZUCKERBERG TO MAKE US THINK THEY
CARE AND VIRTUOUS AND
DISTRACTING US FROM THE REALITY
THEY ARE AND IT IS A PLATFORM
THAT AMPLIFIES VIOLENCE.
I THINK IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
RECONCILE HOW ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY FEEL RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONTENT AND SHUTTING IT DOWN
WHEN THEY HAVE REFUSED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR
PLATFORM THAT LIVE STREAMS GANG
RAPES AND TERRORIST RECRUITMENT
AND SAY WE'RE IN THE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CONTENT AND HERE'S WHY
WE HAVE NOTHING NOVEL AND NOW
THEY CARE ABOUT THIS.
I WAS AN ATTORNEY THAT BROUGHT A
NEGLIGENCE LAWSUIT AGAINST THEM
OR A REPRESENTATIVE DRAFTING
QUESTIONS FOR THE CONGRESSIONAL
INQUIRY I'D ASK HOW THEY FEEL
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS CONTENT AND
NOT AS A WHOLE.
>> Juan: I WAS SURPRISED IN
LOOKING AT THE POLL NUMBERS
PEOPLE THINK FACEBOOK AND THE
OTHER SOCIAL MEDIA FOMENT HATE.
>> Jesse: IF YOU DON'T LIKE
SOMEBODY ON FACEBOOK DON'T
FOLLOW THEM AND I THINK IT'S A
P.R. MOVE SAYING WE HAVE IT
UNDER CONTROL AND GUYS CALL
FACEBOOK AND SAY CAN YOU BAN
THIS PERSON AND PLEASE BAN THIS
PERSON.
IT'S PATHETIC WHERE A MEDIA
COMPANY IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
FREE SPEECH AND YOU SPEND ALL
DAY CALLING TRYING TO SHUT OTHER
PEOPLE'S FREE SPEECH DOWN.
>> Juan: I DON'T KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT?
>> CORRESPONDENTS CALL MEDIA
COMPANIES AND ASK THEM TO BE
SHUT DOWN.
I THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE
EVERYBODY.
MORE FREEDOM IS BETTER THAN LESS
FREEDOM UNLESS THEY'RE INCITING
VIOLENCE, KNOCK THEM OUT.
ONCE WE GET INTO NITPICKING WHO
WE KICK OFF IT'S A SLIPPERY
SLOPE.
>> Juan: KENNEDY, HERE'S A
PROPOSITION, DO YOU THINK WE AS
AN AMERICAN SOCIETY ARE BETTER
OFF WITHOUT THE PROVOCATEURS THE
VOICES OF INCITEMENT AND
FACEBOOK WHERE MOST PEOPLE GET
THEIR NEWS.
>> Kennedy: YOU HAVE BIGGER
PROBLEMS THAN SOMEONE NEEDING TO
BE BANNED.
I DON'T KNOW IT DOES ANYTHING.
IT DOESN'T MAKE THE WORLD SAFER
AND THE NOTION WE HAVE TO BE
ISOLATE FROM IDEAS WE DISAGREE
WITH OR THINGS WE FIND OFFENSIVE
THAT OUR LIVES HAVE TO BE BUBBLE
WRAPPED IS DANGEROUS.
AT SOME POINT AN ENTIRE
GENERATION OF PEOPLE CHA THAT
HAVE BEEN SANITIZED WILL BE
RUNNING THINGS AND THEY'LL BE A
BUNCH OF CREAM PUFFS AND I SHARE
SNOOP DOGG'S FRUSTRATION AND I
KNOW HE WAS FRUSTRATED FVR
ARRAKHA SNV WAS KICKED OFF AND I
BELIEVE IT'S JUST A WAY BECAUSE
MARK ZUCKERBERG HAS SPENT SO
MUCH TIME IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
APOLOGIZING.
WE'RE SO SORRY, WE'LL DO BETTER
AND THIS JUST MAKES IT LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE DOING SOMETHING.
>> Juan: WHAT I NOTICED GREG AND
I'M INTERESTING IN HEARING WHAT
YOU SAID AND I SAW THE NEW
ZEALAND SHOOTER'S HORRIFIC
SLAUGHTER IS STILL ON SOMECYTES
AND
SOME
SOME SITES AND SO I DO THINK IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE ABOUT SOCIAL
MEDIA PERPETRATING HATE SPEECH
AND ALLOWS GROUPS TO FORM THAT
LIKE ISIS AND THE LIKE WHO HAVE
RADICAL EXTREMIST IDEOLOGIES.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S NOTHING
MORE THAN A VIRTUE SIGNAL.
I'D BE A HYPOCRITE IF I
CONDEMNED FACEBOOK FOR THIS
BECAUSE I ALWAYS SAY SOCIAL
MEDIA IT WOULD BE GOOD TO GET
OFF SOCIAL MEDIA, GET IT OUT OF
MY LIFE, I HATE IT BUT IT SEEMED
THEY'RE INCLINED TO POLICE ONE
SIDE OF THE NUT CASES AND NOT
THE OTHERS AND IN OTHER ARENAS
THEY WERE PORTRAYING FARRAKHAN
AS FAR RIGHT.
>> Juan: WASHINGTON POST.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE IN THE MEDIA
THERE'S NO FAR LEFT SO ANYTHING
UNUSUAL OR EXTREMIST IS FAR
RIGHT BUT YOU HAVE TO BE AWARE
BUT IT'S COOL TO BE LABELLED
DANGEROUS.
IF SOMEBODY BANNED ME BECAUSE
I'M DANGEROUS, ROCK 'N ROLL IS
DANGEROUS.
FACEBOOK BAN EXTREMISTS, THE
DEMOCRATS JUST ELECT THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: IF YOU LOOK AT BOOKER
T. WASHINGTON AND OTHERS ARE IN
THAT MIX.
THAT'S NOT THE ISSUE, THE ISSUE
IS WHETHER THE NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS SAID HE'S A
CONSERVATIVE RIGHT-WINGER.